in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory i hear the sound of
winning winning winning
winning winning
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already suppression falls we you
can't hold them i'm soaking wet already
suppression falls now yesterday we had
three big ones really big suppression
balls don't give me the umbrella i'm
soaking wet already they put numbers you
know they're called suppression
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly so you say to your wife you
said your husband darling let's go out
to dinner and then we'll come back we
love our president but you know the
polls say he can't win well right now
we're leading
in almost everywhere the real we're
leading
soaking wet already suppression balls
red wave
i'm soaking wet already suppression
balls
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have take a listen
to this i have not pre-screened this so
i let me just warn you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles
now that your uh your hero is there are
you going to sit there in your little
kimono and wear your little hat
right
it's going to be called no free speech
red chinese communist
speech
but you can't have pork because you
might offend the ayatollahs after all
you're going to love this too they're
going to make a bomb and i hope they
drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork
but you can't have pork
you but you can't have pork just kick
that microphone right up your ass
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are a bunch of wine
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely
[Applause]
you triggered have pork
but you can't have pork moment of the
sexual experience would ask the young
lady who's your daddy this should be
remixed if officer akimov is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
[Music]
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush singer and george bush jr
have been penetrated by at least 100 men
in their anus a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand strong i didn't do it
that's not my problem oh i got down on
my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted
sounds like quite an evening
nose and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
mangoes my bags of mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
seems like a pretty good deal a bag of
mangoes manga aren't mangoes like three
by seats
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
[Music]
bring my mango
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy don't want me to be healthy
[Music]
all right what a special day and we will
have some fruit on the program a little
bit later on today
i really appreciate you joining me super
chat still partially broken partially
broken they will show up
but uh it's all a little bit different
today
i do want to start with a little bit of
a public service announcement
um as many of you know
i am a big fan of the french
chef jacques pepe
who i think makes some of the most
compelling videos on the internet
and because of his recent popularity i
mean i guess during the pandemic a lot
of people watching jacques and watching
his videos people are home cooking etc
and the likes such as
so jimmy fallon decided to invite
jacques pepin to do
his famous omelette technique on the
program
and
it just
fell so flat that i ended up feeling
really bad for the chef
because first of all it wasn't even
really clear that jimmy fallon
knew who jacques papan was
and like there wasn't nearly enough time
for the segment and
it just i ended it it's like jacob fans
85. you made him drive to new york in
from connecticut for such a chaotic
segment where you're talking over him
and like it it really made me upset you
know it really it really did um and i'm
not gonna play it because i think nbc or
whatever channel
uh jimmy fallon's on um
i think they're pretty aggressive from
the standpoint of copyright
but anyway if you guys want to take a
look at it
it it bummed me out a little bit it did
because it could the segment could have
been so much more so so so much more
uh all right welcome everybody we are
gonna go through the full alex jones
situation oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
right
um so anyway we're going to talk about
all of it but as many of you know now
the bonus show has been attacked by alex
jones he has called me a predator i now
have all of these different elements
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pacman right exactly um so
we're going to go through all of it
including the oranges of the whole alex
jones thing and i'll tell some behind
the scenes stories about him and
different things we are going to look at
bill o'reilly's new show and i can't
tell you how boring it is it just i
can't even hate it because it's just so
milk toast
and we're going to do
i'm i'm thinking about doing another
what i call a happy brigade where we
brigade a small youtube channel the way
we did with toontune
and it's brigading in the positive sense
we show up and we subscribe and we leave
comments saying we're here with love
from the david pakman show and i'm
thinking about doing another one people
have been clamoring what's the next
small channel i will support of someone
i know and i have one cued
but i'm kind of going back and forth as
whether today is the day
uh okay here's a super chat sir i want
to re-up my membership but i'm worried
about the fbi learning of my use of the
dangerous discount code what should i do
wait about 30 minutes
and uh then i'm going to have a new code
for you that you can use which
apparently is
impervious
to to the fbi so we're going to get to
that all right let me thank a few people
on twitch and then we're going to get
into the first video sweet thang is a
new twitch subscriber elevated disc golf
the hoosier daddy brown coat loki and
physicist have all made twitch prime
subscriptions which i can't tell you how
much i appreciate we are in the first
hype train of february
february february i'm open to both
and we've got about 80 seconds left to
get to level three so i say we do it i
also want to say thanks to steven
scotthorne for signing up on my website
and leedy lobotomy leedy is also a new
member on my website that is numbers six
and seven oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
right bw rock says happy 38th dp thanks
for the years of informative and
entertaining shows you know what's
really funny
all year round people wish me happy
birthday via super chat and it's not my
birthday it is actually my birthday
today it is legitimately my birthday and
you can confirm that via
uh
wikipedia
as they say
um thanks to sterling lana also for
gifting two subs via twitch i appreciate
that also um ferret queen happy birthday
david do you think infection rates will
get low enough to lift ma max vandat's
mask mandates for vaxxed soon yes i do
i think we're about three weeks from
that to be perfectly frank
um
other people eileen is signing up and
different people are doing all sorts of
different things
and lastly thank you to christine
boehner
for signing up at joinpackman.com you
are new member number 10.
uh all right let's get right into it oh
the bonus show or you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad okay alex jones is now
very triggered by me he did an attack
video on me
what is so funny and kind of sad is alex
jones i don't really know where he's
even on anymore because he's been banned
from most
proper platforms so one place he exists
is
banned dot video that's the website it's
called banned dot video
and
after
two and a half days
the video has only 25 000 views my
reaction video has 325 000 views now i
know many of you will say well you're
giving him publicity no i'm not cause
nobody can see him anywhere
um
okay so anyway he's on band.video and
some other website called [ __ ] hute
i don't even know what these platforms
are but i'm sure they are
self-proclaimed free speech platforms
um let's let's jump into the video and
we'll look at all of it um thanks to mr
bloke's months for the message happy
birthday fellow aquarius saturday's
rally did not disappoint
jd straightshot says what if alex finds
out about the criminally dangerous
discount codes and charged pickles have
he can have at it and danny thompson
sending a 38 super chat on my 38th
birthday i sent a super chat last year
well more like many here is this year's
celebratory chat here's the challenge
match my super chat or grab a website
subscription yeah if any if we want to
do all iterations of 38 like 3801
3802 etc
um
we will uh we will do it all
oh and thanks to tool fan and jen here
for the twitch sub so many things are
happening that i'm struggling to get
going
[Music]
is that happy birthday in uh maybe
an indigenous new zealand language
geez
happy birthday may this year bring all
the calzones
and uncharged pickles hold on do i have
calzones here
by the way how are the calzones right
and congratulations for not falling off
the earth during your 38th orbit around
the sun
thank you
birthday twins 2 2 22. it's my birthday
as well happy birthday to you talissa
um sir happy birthday thank you for your
excellent coverage and reminding us of
our wives airborne status
yes very very important sir your wife is
up in the air a lot of our audience's
spouses are up in the air
david do you believe alex jones says do
do you think alex jones believes the bs
he says on his show i actually don't
um doesn't make it any less bad
but i actually don't all right let's get
right into video number one
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there right who thinks he's
smarter than you thinks he's better than
you and he's gonna beat you he thinks
pac-man never talked to the new world
war pac-man never got tried to get hired
by the kissinger group because pac-man's
a loser he's a sell-out he's not a real
man
he's not a knight at the round table he
didn't actually have a real discussion
with the power structure he worships see
i said no to the evil power structure
i don't it's hard to imagine that anyone
could believe this crap you know because
i was a hero because i had god i had a
connection to the infinite i knew this
was a failure this was not good it would
be great if alex jones debated jesse lee
peterson where jesse lee would be like
david's a beta and alex jones would be
like no no no he's a dangerous predator
and they'd have to figure it out i
didn't join with god and justice because
i was a good person i did it because i
had discernment
with god
a disturbing image
also by the way a lot of people in the
chat say they're like that this segment
from alex jones is hard to follow yeah i
have no idea why he's even upset
[Music]
so now we look at the spirit of judas
iscariot
betraying themselves betraying humanity
serving sorrows serving schwab serving
by serving balchi
[Music]
then i've got some more news i want to
hit here
by the way
how is
is he like a bodybuilder or is he just
overweight i know it's sort of out of
school but i am fascinated by the
physical evolution like i think alex
jones is only two years older than me
um how old is he
oh no oh my god no he's like 10 years
older than me yeah but doesn't he look
much more than 10 years older than me
like it's just a very strange evolution
so this is just a
snapshot of the bizarreness of acting
like a tape call as a call
and then nodding with it and talking to
it now you guys know
that we play voicemails on the call on
the show but we also take live calls we
like we take live calls at least once a
week and people are able to ask me about
anything
anything we don't even screen it you can
ask me about anything
so i'm not pretending the voicemails are
live calls it's just a voicemail segment
that's what it is because you're so
scared to actually talk to people scared
and give them the power of being live we
take we open the phone lines and people
can ask about anything anything they
want jones has fake callers
jones has fake reviews because they're
fake because they rig everything because
they're so scared they gotta control it
all
and then to here cause we can show you
the raspberries from poll nobody wants
to put you in a camp that's a democrat
nobody wants to arrest you nobody wants
to have political prisoners no no no no
no no no that at this point i already
have no idea what he's talking about i
don't know how this even relates to me
the republicans that support trump
who are the ragtag group trying to get
back control of the country
but could we get martial out of
republicans absolutely could that party
be just as bad with neocons running it
yes but the neocons are allied with the
democrats they're the ones pushing all
this on record here it is
i don't know how this relates male
number that number is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail i received with a
very practical like why is that even
funny why is the number funny simple
question about if it came time to leave
the country would you still be able to
leave the country it's a very good
question
hi david i just heard you say on the
stream that if the united states becomes
a full-blown dictatorship like i'm not
pretending it's a live call it literally
says voicemail line
what's
how am i pretending it's live by 2024
yeah you will be leaving the country so
i've been thinking about this a lot
myself and
is it too late
if you wait until it's a full-blown
dictatorship will you even be able to
leave the country if you're that
concerned about it happening should you
be making plans my segment which is
which says voicemail line is me
pretending it's a live caller
it goes full-blown dictatorship yeah
this is a fair question which is like
all right hit pause back it up five
seconds i'm not gonna edit this i want
you to hurt
i feel bad for alex jones that he's like
if it's sad that i'm reacting to
voicemails how sad is it that alex jones
is reacting to me reacting to voicemails
on a website called bitchute right i
mean like what are the layers here
they admit and i've played the clips
from the davos group that you and all of
it that it's a world id where you won't
be able to travel leave your house quote
one half foot if you don't have the
vaccine passport and i have a whole
stack of articles i'll show you about
that and they're saying that that
republicans are the ones that passed the
law to put put kill switches in all the
cars which is now law
and i mean
the republicans are i don't know how
this relates to the voicemail i
genuinely have no idea horrible weak
pathetic cowardly
folks on average i don't like them but
but they're not the people in the
driver's seat like the democrats and
imagine though this fear porn though the
trump supporters are going to have a
dictatorship
are you kidding
george soros has got almost every
district attorney by the way
it is not lost on me
that there are serious anti-semitic
undertones here for sure an attorney
general under his control and you sit
there and act like you're not the
establishment that is a lie on its face
continue with this garbage
this is a fair question which is like
if things completely changed overnight
in the u.s
and all of a sudden no one was allowed
to leave the plan of saying i will stay
if and until it gets really bad
doesn't work because if it got so bad
you wouldn't be allowed to leave i don't
you know when we talk about the canadian
political scientists who said the u.s
could be yeah back in five seconds you
know exactly no no let's see i've got
the media you've got the universities
you've got the military you've got the
banks you've got hollywood and you're po
you're like hey don't worry you don't
need to leave we're raping america
really good we got drag queen story time
going on okay we got the evaluation of
the dollar we got cloud pivot we're
gutting this [ __ ]
we're revolutionaries we're alpha males
we're going to screw this country like a
tad billy goat
that's a little translation
the exhilaration of joining with does
anybody know what he's talking about the
evil the exhilaration of joining with
the u.n the exhilaration of joining with
klaus schwab the exhilaration of you're
a team player you get lots of money now
let's continue
us could be a dictatorship by 2030 or
whatever else the case may be
i believe that will it would be a
continued slow slide in that direction
and i am counting on the the more
projection that's what they're doing
that i would have time to get out if
such a time came what is his criticism
of me now would i if it's so slow that
the frog doesn't realize it's getting
burned right total projection would i
know when it's time to leave these are
all fair questions but i don't think it
would be like an overnight no
so they're doing this to us classical
corporate takeover censorship debanking
arrest tyranny
collapsing and then he's talking about
them as victims talk about talk about a
fantasy talk about a simulation he's in
his own but he knows it's not a
simulation he loves this for his little
groveling followers that actually drink
this kool-aid that's you guys by the way
that he's talking about that's that you
so this is this segment is not only
about me this is about all of you
he's talking about all of you guys
that's everybody on tv and youtube and
and facebook
tick tocks
yeah not enough of your groveling is the
problem i would have actually there
needs to be more groveling please hey
let's continue
yes uh but maybe some people in the
audience uh have a different perspective
on the bonus show today
we will talk about the five that's
enough oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad
the attack on the bonus show is maybe
the best moment in the history of this
program
i i i think if we were to talk about the
top moments ever on the show
they would be
when anonymous hacked westboro baptist
church right i mean that i think that
has to be a top moment
um
man would our i don't even know what the
other moment are there even good moments
on this show i don't even know
um
what else would be up there i guess
i guess that and this
i mean it's kind of sad
uh i mean the insurrection stream i know
what you guys are saying but but it's it
was such like a sad event
um
i don't know
anyway it's hard to imagine a better
moment than the attack on the bonus show
if i was telling my children who not to
be it's that guy right i mean he's a
disgrace
and i don't say that like god i feel
good about myself no he makes me feel
pathetic
good
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pacman that's a cautionary tale
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you thinks
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks
i'm gone
no joe rogan and uh bill maher they're
all smarter than you big man
because you know they've they've uh
played both sides but now they know
who's gonna win
you're on the wrong side of history
i guess that applies to you guys too
like i'm interpreting everything he's
saying
also applies to you guys like we're it's
collectively we're all on the wrong side
according to him
and i'm so sorry
for what's going to happen to you
by your own decisions
but he's an archetype
arc
type
i build arcs
a sample out of the fetid
latrine or cesspool that is the system
is that's the vanguard that's the that's
the stay behind network that's the
scorched earth
leavings they've got as as the
globalists back off to armored
fortresses
oh he said globalist
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad okay
and and dig into their underground basis
literally
you think the people that have the
underground bases call up people like
pac-man
no
you know
interestingly i mean i can't even really
talk about that i shouldn't even be
opening up the door
but he's wrong about that
he's wrong about that the under the i
mean the the underground bait the people
with the underground bases not calling
me thing
i can't i'm not even allowed to tell you
guys
how wrong that is right now
pac-man never talked to the new world
order pac-man never got tried to get
hired by the kissinger group because
pac-man's a loser he's a sell-out he's
not a real man
he's not a knight at the round table he
didn't actually have a real discussion
with the power structure he worships see
i said no to the evil power structure
not because i was a hero but because i
had god i had a connection to the
infinite i knew this was a failure this
was not good i didn't join with god and
justice because i was a good person i
did it because i had discernment and
wanted to be with god right
mr pac-man is not with god
i guess this is all because i'm jewish
it seems at the end of the day and he is
everything you don't want to be
what a day
what are these websites band dot video
future news news it's bizarre
i want to tell you about sale that we've
just launched especially if you have not
properly prepped for a disaster uh-oh 10
off all storable foods at
infowarsstore.com there you go insurance
the globalists have crept out of the
shadows and are now openly trying to
destabilize the entire planet and in my
opinion now is the most crucial time to
stock up on storable food and get ready
so it's not even a 12-minute segment
because four minutes is selling
red beans i guess saved time and money
later not to mention insurance you can
eat in a crisis ten percent off all
storable food right now ten percent hard
to turn that deal down all right guys so
that's that that's the full alex jones
segment and it's completely and utterly
insane but in celebration of the
insanity that me triggering alex jones
is
we have a new coupon code because he
called me a predator and that code is
predator22
first person to use it on my website
gets a free item from the online store
t-shirt hat mug whatever you want first
person to use it predator 22 at
jointpakman.com i'll keep an eye on
who's first and you'll get a free item
and that includes the world famous
and
frequently attacked bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right
exactly right
um okay hillary says happy birthday
fellow aquarius i think the photos
picked of you were handsome shots yeah i
don't exactly look evil in the pictures
that uh alex jones picks of me right i
mean it's like these are not exactly
they're sort of like schoolboy pictures
to some degree
um david sir please make thank god i am
not david pakman shirts i know i should
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pagman right
so i've got that on the sound board and
i also have mech cell co mexico
and we will ban men right so i have all
of those different things now
um on the sound board which is which is
really really exciting stuff
uh okay let me get okay so we're gonna
get next to the sam sader
um
analysis of the alex jones thing but
before we do that jimmy from philly had
a perspective on it on the alex jones
thing here is jimmy from philly's
opinion about it
david jimmy from philly what
so i watched the alex jones thing he
spanked you with new ass
now do any of us believe that jimmy
knows what alex was talking about
because none of us have any idea what
alex jones was talking about but somehow
we're supposed to believe
jimmy understood what that insane rant
was all about oh
oh god that was good oh david
david and you're talking about like
leaving the country are you that afraid
you should be
because all that [ __ ] you propagated
to your 15 year old audience david take
your 124 million
and [ __ ] go to some
some [ __ ] spanish country or
something
how many spanish countries are there i
guess just spain right like that's the
only spanish country
spanish speaking is a different story
but work for you write your spanish
right no i'm not spanish no i'm
argentinian
oh man when your [ __ ] goes down david
heads are gonna roll
oh god it's funny because they
simultaneously
laugh about the idea that people might
want or need to leave the country
but then they seem to be saying
when it goes down heads are going to
roll that's why people call me and they
go david if you had to leave the country
where would you go
it's
you know
it's it's really something else uh okay
let oh wow hold on the first person to
use the new coupon code predator22
and win themselves a free item from the
david pakman show online store
is richard clark using the coupon code
predator22
you were new member number 13 today also
joining on my website with the new alex
jones coupon code oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad matthew burkhard is a new member
scott labrie
polly the pug
melissa tarnoff
chris veale
farron joinby
and tom denny
all signing up with the new coupon code
predator22
also over on twitch let's kick up the
twitch stuff i want to say thanks to
regional manager vader who says the mike
pillow interview is high on my list that
is a classic moment from the show that's
a good point
j.p de beast has re-upped his sub
um so
solene polka king
ryan rincon my friend sean brain matter
another ryan rincon
sheldon black bran barbs have all signed
up via twitch and twitch prime and
related twitch products putting us at
29. and lastly amanda worshing
is a new member using the coupon code
predator 22. oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
right um
happy birthday david hope you have a
great day also do you recommend any
place to eat out in buenos aires oh my
god there are so many restaurants but so
many things have closed during the
pandemic i couldn't recommend any
specific places right now
uh but the food is fantastic in buenos
aires and um
i i highly recommend it okay let's go
now
to sam cedar um commenting on the alex
jones thing today he did a whole thing
about it
we've talked about this in the past
as you know
we sit in front of
custom made
backdrops
both emma and i yeah who are custom made
by
yours well i should say customized
because they are ikea
panels
that
i customized okay by putting uh a gel
behind it and and some lights and then
got some stickers
and put them on
took a lot of work
a lot of ingenuity
a lot of imagination
a lot of effort
and it was stolen from me
stolen
right out from behind me
by that man
you can see the the panels there and
then he's just haunting you yeah
he glossed it up too like like look at
all look what i can do i've got a
vertical
tv screen yeah yeah i mean
right absolutely and i don't know if he
knows but the blue go back to that the
blue doesn't even match what it is on
the tv but never mind that's not the
point it is about time
that someone called this guy out
for the stealing of my panels yeah and
that almost happened
when alex jones called him out the other
day right unlikely ally yeah
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
he thinks he's smarter than you and he's
better than you and he's gonna beat you
he thinks pac-man never talked to the
new world order pac-man never got tried
to get hired by the kissinger group
because pac-man's a loser he's a
sell-out he's not a real man
he's not a knight at the round table he
didn't actually have a real discussion
all right power structure this is what i
have been saying
for years
you can't come and take
this idea for a backdrop
when you're not a knight at the round
table this is our excalibur
don't you understand
you are weak
you don't deserve this panel
you're not you you don't
you've never
unsheathed the sword
you have not a euphemism no you have no
idea
you wouldn't know gwynevere if she was
sitting across the table from you
you have no armor
wait are there people in the chat who
don't recognize that this is all a joke
it saddens me that there are people who
think this is for real i've had
conversations off air with sam where we
go
it's crazy that people think this is for
real isn't it and we're like yeah it's
it's crazy it's it's really crazy
and no one's list
you would never
be sent into battle by kissinger
that's all that
predator
praying on my set
you prayed on my set
what else keep playing this this is
completely nonsensical
i don't know why he attacked him when i
was texting with sam about this he also
couldn't understand why that
silly voicemail clip was what triggered
alex jones it doesn't make any sense
but you'd think if anything one of my
clips about alex jones would be what
triggers him
but it's
hilarious i said no to the evil power
structure
not because i was a hero but because i
had god i had a connection
i knew this was a failure this was not
good i didn't join with god and justice
because i was a good person
i did it because i had discernment and
wanted to be with god
all right go forward that was just the
uh promo thing or something
so now
yeah i keep going
it doesn't matter what you know it's
going to be nonsensical
humanity serving sorrows serving swabs
serving seriously
and then i've got some more news i want
to hit here
so this is just a
snapshot of the bizarreness of acting
like a tape call as a call
and then nodding with it and talking to
it because you're so scared to actually
talk to people
give them the power of being live
so the left always claims jones has fake
callers
jones has fake reviews because they're
fake because they rig everything because
they're so scared
does is he has voicemails that he plays
voicemails on his show
we take calls
but i mean we remember when alex because
i
am a member of the of the knights of the
round table i'm very uh religious guy
actually god is with me yeah i'm
heavenly person not because it's the
good thing to do but because god's
[ __ ] cool i didn't yeah i didn't want
to
he just chose me
not because i'm a
hero just because
i won the lottery is that god's stuff is
that a new emphasis or has he always
sort of been doing
i also wonder if it doesn't have
something to do with pac-man's
soros
and see any of the um
any of the comments yes underneath
jones's thing yes
it is very very um
specific a lot of comments
are um dealing with the fact that
pac-man is jewish it's odd that's odd so
odd
it is like
your point about alex jones like the cia
would have created him if if he didn't
exist and who knows like he's the
perfect
vessel for
for god no for uh like conspiracy
theorizing that like you make it all
about the jews as opposed to capital
right capitalists right uh and uh and
then you think about media members too
like
not a structure of capitalism
it is the bilderberger group and of
course the jews who who uh
run the uh the mannequins there right
you make a conspiracy out of like vince
foster instead of what neoliberal
capitalism is doing that's right 90s
yeah yeah david pakman dragged
this set
into the park
left it there buried
dragged my set in there
yep so there you go
um
david pacquiao i can't i mean i watched
the video and to be honest with you i
couldn't quite make out what exactly it
was that alex jones decided i don't know
if that means that like jones is like
our numbers are down i want you to pick
some
jewish youtuber right
pacman probably went out who's got um
1.3 million uh subscribers no but like
this is what happened hey whoa hold on
1.4 million now now see that's an attack
we can't have that that's erasing a
hundred thousand of you guys
we can't have any of this we're not
gonna do the 1.3 business now
soon to be 1.5 please
happened when we did that video on him
he didn't do it or we did that right
yeah no it was a video
like about um
and sam harris right
did you not remember this then he
covered our uh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah oh he got confused
yeah i forgot about that
i forgot about he didn't understand that
he thought we were being interviewing
sam harris
i've gotten confused by this without the
voicemails and the uh all the different
voices coming from different places
sensory overload
god did not choose me to understand
what's going on
that's it
bring back sam cedars set
that's what we want to hear
that's what i want
now damn it
mean
one world order yeah the way sam does
the voice does seem like it would be bad
for your for your voice and throat i try
to do it you know i do it in this way
where i'm not doing uh that thing
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialists unlike obama trudeau mccrown
and the rest of these zio beasts
somehow i'm doing it in a way that
doesn't doesn't hurt my throat i have to
accept people according all of the
panels
we have to accept like when somebody
becomes de-radicalized and comes to the
right side of the political spectrum we
have to accept them it doesn't matter
who it is including alex jones joining
the majority report in the fight against
david yes we will accept the the ally
ship
um
and this this fight will not end
until until
every one of those panels is destroyed
right
i want to see it on air i want to see
proof
of
destruction of the panels perhaps with
excalibur
yes
what is excalibur anyway is that pulling
a sword out of a stone is that excalibur
i don't even know what that means i want
a sword
a massive saber
stuck through every one of those panels
shattered
um all right let's get to um okay by the
way i do want to tell you guys something
and i'm i'm telling you this for real
right now
actually hold on let me thank a few
people and then i'm going to reveal
something here
um
fast n ain't life a horror or a hara
as bernie would say
christian pewter
i fifo
matthew weavesly and then five gifted
subs from jay tandaway
puts us at 40 which is a really strong
place to be and then
massive dumps of website memberships i
want to say thanks to christine gower
as well as jenner dangers
ryan rincon
michael blaylock
and john hall as well as matt fisher all
using the new
coupon code predator 22
and these are the oranges of that coupon
code
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there so predator 22
is uh is the coupon while since we've
updated the set
we
are working on
working on
totally redesigning the set here
and if we do that
i might
burn slash blow up this entire set or we
could look at maybe donating it to the
smithsonian or something like that uh if
they would want it as you know just a
reminder of this dark time in
independent media history but
i would be
willing i would be willing to consider
something funny
something funny with the set
like maybe uh how big is the screen i
think this is a 46 i believe this is a
46. i would consider for example we do
an auction
where it goes up by a dollar
and the top person gets to put a sign
which we will order huge
and then burn everything we'll put the
sign on the panels and then burn the
entire thing with the message that is
the winning message
um
yeah i don't know i don't know you know
i'm open to different ideas but in the
meantime so you guys can send me ideas
on what to do when we're ready to get
rid of this set and then also
um
what else maybe i would do excalibur
maybe i would get a saber and puncture
this thing so we could look at that
maybe i'll send him back to sam that's a
good idea too
and then i don't know that i have too
much to say about the new set yet but we
are looking at something pretty clean
and modern
which might include
bringing in a brick wall we might do an
angled brick wall which might actually
be on casters so it could be moved in
and out
and then uh we're actually there there's
a window behind that so we could even be
looking out the window and then so like
when it's snowing versus when it's sunny
we would have kind of like a more
seasonal element to it might have to put
some film on the window for it to
display correctly because things can get
weird with cameras when you've got
backlight so we're gonna look at that
um
and then over here we may even get like
we have the new logo actually the logo
down there that's not even the new logo
we need a new we haven't even updated it
there is a new logo let me see if it's
here it's not anyway the new logo we
might get done in metal
and we would put it over here on this so
anyway it's a totally different look i
don't know it's something we're thinking
about
uh
but when it comes time we might do a
ceremonial destruction of this set at
some point in time okay a few super
chats coming in
david i love you but you're the least
threatening predator i have ever seen
beta
exactly
um is pacman part of the socialist
elitist soyboy carhart wearing culture
sure but he never took part in an
insurrection that's true
that's that's absolutely true
and lastly thank you to paul doherty for
signing up with the coupon code predator
22.
uh okay let me get to a few other things
um
hold on what do i have here oh okay this
is this is kind of more sad than
anything else
bill o'reilly and lou dobbs both lost
their shows
did why did lou dobbs lose his lose his
he just said something crazy right
bill o'reilly i think it was for sexual
assault allegations but what what was it
that look lou dobbs said something and
they kicked him off the air
do you guys remember
yeah i know guys we're not going to burn
anything it will everything's going to
be safe don't worry anyway lou dobbs and
bill bill o'reilly both lost their shows
okay
so now bill o'reilly has a show i guess
just on his website
and he invented
uh he invited rather lou dobbs and it's
so boring it's just like two old guys
yelling get off my lawn
talking about like it's hard what
they're saying is dumb but i don't even
care i feel nothing like i when i used
to watch bill o'reilly i would go wow
that's really weaponized that's really
bad
um
but now when i watch this i'm like who
even cares nobody's listening it's just
this is the most boring show ever check
this out
should the government be worried that
there's 10 million vacant jobs or does
it matter
well not to the government the
government right now can't do much more
i mean think about where we are we've
got eight and a half trillion dollars on
the balance sheet of the fed uh we've
got a deficit uh that's over a
billion dollars uh this year we're going
to trillion now it's crazy because it's
like they've been yelling about all the
exact same stuff for 30 years now it's
always we're on the verge guys
this
sound money and all these different
things and guys listen you know
my background isn't economics there's
real economic questions around debt
deficit for sure but it's the exact same
complaints for 30 years and they they
just go nowhere and now they're just
they're it's just sort of they're
throwing bouquets at each other you have
another
i think it's a isn't it over a trillion
dollar deficit or a billion is it a b or
a did i say billion i meant trillion
uh and we're looking at two trillion uh
for the next year and a half as well uh
we're on our way as you pointed out
to 33 trillion dollars in debt on an
economy that is wow what an analysis i
haven't heard this analysis from every
sort of like right-wing media figure for
30 years and yet
it it never goes anywhere well by the
way that'll make us larger than our
economy and our debt uh and it's it's
just it's as you said unsustainable and
there's no secret about it even
even janet yellen the treasury secretary
has to be able to convey that reality to
to joe biden but apparently not because
he wants five trillion dollars wow what
an incisive critique guys
we're gonna spend more money more money
and more money okay
but i'm ready about the folks now so you
got 10 trillion so anybody who wants to
work and work
uh wages are rising very very fast right
a dollar 33
in one year on average yeah now notice
that
they don't praise biden for that this is
a fast and this is absolutely
fascinating
all of trump's presidency he was
bragging about wages rising wages the
blacks and the hispanics and the asians
they have higher wages higher wages
the wages were going up for the same
reason that they're going up now which
is a combination of
employees having a little more market
power to negotiate
part of the reason the wages are going
up is because people are saying well
i i'm demanding better conditions
and
also because of minimum wage increases
to some degree so
under trump it was great that wages were
going up
now it's like you know wages are up this
is not sustainable average wage is 31 an
hour which is pretty damn good all right
now i don't know where that number comes
from that may be averaging in you know
it
i it doesn't doesn't even matter right
that's right so
wages are doing well and and that's what
the buying administration is pointing to
economies go go go go now they don't
talk a lot about inflation
that eats up most of the wages but how
do you balance that
the the balance and point of fact right
now is in favor of labor without
question and by the way it's overdue we
went through 25 years bill in this
country where wages
are were stagnant oh now that's okay
that's a good point okay no no now lou
dobbs is making a good point i like that
now
now he's saying yeah the wage increases
are overdue okay credit to lou dobbs
where credit is due i still don't care
about the segment but it's something uh
25 years for the middle class and those
immediately uh
uh trying to work into the middle class
well based in blue pilled uh and we are
looking at a really a solution to a huge
problem and that is a lack of equity in
our income
for wages primarily uh in the workforce
and that's and that is working through
this is an economy a market that's
actually doing what it should
now there has to be a point at which we
get to equilibrium as the economists
like to call it all right where is that
is that a year from now two years uh but
meanwhile we have another issue which is
the senior citizens in this country who
are living uh in part on their social
security uh who have investments uh that
are being depreciated because of high
inflation so that too is going to have
to
to be watched but the truth is there's
not much we can do all right so the the
lou dobbs analysis is marginally less
crazy than i thought
however i assume that the solutions he
would propose i don't agree with but the
whole point here is
it's very hard to feel like you know
when we watch crazy fox segments and
tucker it's like i feel like wow that's
really bad so we need to do something
about that that's terrible what he's
saying we got to fight with this it's
like yeah let him say whatever they want
i don't know no one's really even
watching this stuff it's just kind of
it's depressing in some sense depressing
in some sense uh okay you guys want to
do um
you want to do a brigade should we do a
brigade right now i do have a new
brigade to announce let me see if i can
find
the last brigade that we did
was the toontoon
youtube channel
um which i believe when we announced the
brigade
they toontoon it's a thai cooking
channel this guy i know great great
channel i think he was at like
1500
subscribers and we got thousands and
thousands of new subscribers for
toontoon uh i have a new brigade to
announce now i want to warn you guys
this is a brigade of a channel with hold
on let me see
this is a brigade of a channel
with 17 subscribers so we potentially
are going to
wreak total havoc on a friend of mine
and here's the deal
um
yes and i remember the twitter brigade
we once twitter brigaded my friend
michael cusack on twitter he has a
cannabis magazine and he um
he had it set up where his phone would
buzz every time he got a twitter
follower
and you guys literally woke him up from
a nap it was crazy so here's the brigade
i'm going to announce a friend of mine
who used to be my manager at circuit
city
uh 20 years ago
is now
in the
luxury watch industry and he has no idea
what he's doing yet on youtube in his
first uh he's doing one of these where
he like he he
tracks he he has like a like a day in
the life type thing
his website is called crafted time
crafted time and i'll paste the link he
has literally two videos and 17
subscribers and i think we can probably
completely blow this up
uh and i think he still has
notifications turned on for every single
new subscriber now make sure we do this
say you're coming with love from the
david pakman show
let's just see what we can do
this he just launched his brother is
filming for him they had vertical video
in the first episode and i told him
roman we used to know him as the ukraine
train he's from ukraine at circuit city
i said roman
you got to get that video horizontal
it's absolutely crazy all right we got
him to 101 already he is gonna have a
ball with this
um
let's
157 man
there it is look at that
uh i mean like 17 subscribers it's it's
just it's a wild wild time
uh where are we at 206.
and you gotta remember the comments have
to say david pakman sent me because
otherwise we yeah maybe we'll send him
the old set when we're done with it uh
that's not a bad idea
um 249. we couldn't i mean we couldn't
possibly get him
to a thousand right i just don't think
we have the viewership right now
um probably not
that would be insane yeah this is a
positive use of the platform this is a
positive brigade
uh look at these numbers 303.
uh oh and welcome to everybody coming
from jeff waldorf's channel on twitch
very much appreciate that uh we're
brigading a friend of mine's new youtube
channel he had 17 subscribers about a
minute ago and now he's up to 350.
um
yeah
it's it is the the you know i don't know
how many people love this stuff but
there's this new format on youtube i'm
always interested in the trends on
youtube there's a format where like
high-end watch dealers film everything
they're doing and roman's idea was he's
just starting from scratch he doesn't
really know what he's doing yet and so
he actually is um
filming everything that's going on and
he's got himself the gloves and
everything he's a real character i've i
have some roman stories journey of a
beginning watch dealer
got an appointment coming in
to look at the grand seiko
221. i know nothing about watches like i
know literally nothing about watches but
he brings people in the look at this guy
with cash
who carries around cash like this for a
while like the entire world is just
crazy for me
it's it's completely insane
anyway
so uh that's that's the brigade today
and he's up to uh 437 455 let's let's
see if we can get him to 500 and then
we'll move on and i'm curious oh hold on
did he already text me hold on a second
no he didn't he didn't yet
all right at a certain point i'm
assuming i'm gonna detect all right very
good um oh people bring the tattoo
people bring cash that's interesting
that's interesting all right so there it
is crafted time
um i'll paste the link a couple more
times
just for people who don't know what's
going on and then i will let you guys
know if i get a message from roman and
see what happens did we did we hit it
um 484 we're very very close 485.
uh grand seiko is one of the greatest
watchmakers yeah i don't know anything
about i literally know nothing about
watches uh 498 oh my god i think we're
gonna do it
i think we're about to do it
people like grand seiko
are we there
498
there it is oh wow from 17 to 5 17.
uh okay good all right so there's that
let's move on to a couple of other
things um okay where do i have here oh
i've been asked to do
a fruit
tear maker hold on let me see list
because we know that fruit is a big part
of my show so i will do this and you
know i've come out and said that i
believe that the sumo orange is the best
citrus fruit that is out there i'm not
going to spend a lot of time on this but
it will give you guys a little bit of a
sense of where my where i am on fruits
and various other elements of fruit now
is an avocado even a fruit i believe it
is avocado a fruit
uh it is a fruit okay so let's just
let's just jump right in okay i'm gonna
go fruit by fruit for me i put avocado i
think it's absolutely fantastic for me
avocado goes at the top
avocado toast very very hard to beat it
avocado in salads
it's really hard to beat an avocado okay
apple apple is a fruit that i have had
an apple basically every day for the
last 20 years i prefer
green apples granny smith now even
though this is a picture of a red apple
i'm still gonna put apple at the top i
think it's absolutely extraordinary it's
an extraordinary apple
um okay bananas i have loved bananas
since i was a kid when i was one i
actually had to go on a baby diet i was
going a little too crazy with the
bananas and the pediatrician said let's
limit the bananas to every other day i
consider bananas fantastic but not at
the level of apple and avocado so i'm
gonna put banana at a
is this is this a blackberry can people
tell what this even is right here
is that a blackberry
do we know
it's a blackberry okay
i absolutely love blackberries but
sometimes find them to be a little bit
tart
i still consider blackberry to be a very
very strong fruit and i would put it at
a as you can tell i like fruit so i
think it's biased up to some degree okay
blueberry
this may be controversial i'm not big on
blueberries i don't dislike them i don't
dislike them but it's it's not i don't
love it the way some people do
um
so i would put blueberries at
b or c
i mean blue i think blueberry is a c for
me dog
i think that's going to be a c for me i
i don't i'm just not i don't know that i
can really in good conscience do it any
higher uh
cantaloupe i i i do like cantaloupe it's
not
i i prefer watermelon and i prefer
honeydew
i think so i'm gonna put cantaloupe as a
b
cherries
i absolutely love
love cherries
they can be a little bit hit or miss
but it is a top fruit i would put
cherries at
a
grapes is really tough because there's
so many varieties of grapes i am partial
to seedless green
and among the green grapes the lighter
the green the better i tend to find the
smaller darker green grapes less good i
like the large
lightest possibly colored ones
um and it's just so tough it really
should be broken down by by varietal i'm
not a big fan of the cotton candy grapes
something about it just turns me off i
think it's the smell smell smells very
uh fake
um so i would put grapes at um man i do
like i would put grapes as an a
i'm not a big grapefruit guy i will
admit i'm not a big grapefruit guy i
would put grapefruit
it's really like a b minus for me
um
[Music]
i probably put grape i'm gonna put
grapefruit at a c just to be a little
bit
you know
uh dramatic
guys do we even need to talk about where
mango goes i don't even i don't i don't
know that i need to insult the audience
in this way
um
do i need to talk about where mango goes
i don't i don't even okay yeah let's
just let's put it mangoes absolutely
perfect fruit
oranges so
if this was sumo citrus or a satsuma
mandarin i think we would be very
strongly looking at
ester oranges are really hit or miss
really hit or miss um
but it is still i mean a good orange you
know a tangelo for example
uh is a great fruit do i put orange at
an a or a b
no i look
do i like oranges is about as much as
cantaloupe i'm going to put orange at a
b and if we had it further broken down
i think there are some some varieties
where i would go to a for sure
i am not a big peach guy
and i know that that's sacrilegious to
summon the audience i'm not i just can't
lie to you guys
i'm not huge on peaches for me a peach
is below
an orange and a cantaloupe so i think
for me a peach is is a c
oh pineapple is a really tough fruit to
grade
pineapple can be so good
and it can also be vile it can also be
vile
um
like your average pineapple where would
i put it
i oh man that's really tough i think for
me a pineapple is a bee
i think for me it's going to be a bee
um
okay pomegranate
i i want to be really careful not to
insult anybody
i don't fully understand
the whole pomegranate thing it's like
some people say you just kind of have to
suck the flesh off of the seeds other
people say you bite and eat the seeds
i don't really like eating pomegranate
seeds i don't particularly like
pomegranate juice
and so for me
i'm going to put pomegranate at a d
it's just not for me
it's really just not for me
now raspberry is a fruit i can really
get behind
i'm almost thinking man raspberry i
think i have to reorganize i'm going to
move blackberry down to b
and put raspberry at a and here's my
thinking and tell me if you think this
um
this thinking makes sense
i like raspberries more than
blackberries
but raspberries are not here for me so
it seems to me that it's proper to put
the raspberry at a
and push the blackberry down to b you
don't have to agree with my thinking but
do you at least understand it is it
internally logical
it's not okay all right well i apologize
i apologize
um okay
so i'm not a big strawberry guy uh i i'm
just gonna put strawberries at b
you know strawberries can be good and
sometimes they're not they're not so
good and watermelon without any question
whatsoever
is an s tier fruit it is absolutely an
ester fruit now when the watermelon's
not good
okay you know then it's a different
story
but uh at its current you know the your
ideal watermelon
seedless
for sure seedless for sure
um you know what people are saying i
should really rethink the banana
i don't think you're wrong i'm gonna
i think now i'm gonna make some
adjustments i'm pulling banana down
now i'm second guessing orange
this is a general estimate guys okay
this is a general estimate and we're
missing a number of fruits here first of
all tomatoes a fruit and we should
really have that here
orange should be broken down by type for
example i don't love a blood orange i
just don't think it's that good i just
don't think it's that good honeydew
should be on here
um we should have tangelo
um clementine
cuties all of these things should be
broken down separately and if dragon
fruit were here i would put the red
dragon fruit at a b
and i would put the yellow and i'm
talking about the outside i would put
the yellow dragon fruit also known as a
yellow pitaya at an a
um
kiwi you know we i would probably put
kiwi at
b
uh okay so anyway this gives you guys
just a kind of a sense of it okay this
is where i am uh on the standpoint of
fruit axel says hard disagree on
pineapple they need a
they're the only fruit angry enough to
eat you back bromelain i don't know
anything about that
where would i put honeydew i would
probably put honeydew at a b
i think
kumquats i had a kumquat it wasn't it
wasn't that good i'm not going to lie
really wasn't that good all right let me
say thanks to a few people confirm
disconfirm 6lj
another from confirmed disconfirm also
gordon z hall and vatarette have made
twitch prime subscriptions putting us at
52 over on my website i want to say
thank you to colin fraser
who now will have access to the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad exactly
all right let's continue but back by
popular demand we're going to do another
round of geo guesser geo guesser let's
do it uh we are doing classic geoguessr
and we are doing world geoguessr let's
play
all right
let's play geoguessr and see where we
are
okay
it is english
this makes me think it's probably the
united states
although
it looks like cars are driving on the
left side of the road which would push
me towards australia or the united
kingdom
um
and it indeed says australian unity so
now i am thinking we are in australia we
are in australia
let's see if we can identify i mean i'm
not a big australia expert
so it could be pretty tough to get
more specific than that
uh
let's
see here is a particular
honda dealership
peter stevens honda that doesn't really
tell me too too much
let's see if we can find
some other indication of where we are
still have four minutes
laurie ogle motors on mercer street
it means nothing to me
it means absolutely nothing to me the
bell mercer motel
uh burson auto parts
lucky strike gold prospecting
a gym of some kind
i'm looking for something that would
narrow down where we are
texas hamburgers oh no what are they
doing to australia texas pizza house
they have a texas oh god there's a kfc
what are they doing to australia
it it is a tragedy what is happening
let's see what else we've got here
peter stevens a very strong presence
here
uh we've got a europe car
jay carr
qualitool looking for any indication of
where
specifically we might be
the phone number does nothing for me
whoa hold on a second that's not where
we need to be right now
let's see what else we've got
kia motors winter and taylor
use it's just like a car sales area
traditional thai massage uh-oh oh boy
it's getting a little bit
edgy
let's see what else we have here
holden
sir charles we're down to two minutes
left here
and collectibles on mercer i really
don't have any basis
on which i could guess where in
australia we are
winter and taylor
um all right so i think in terms of a
guess
the bigger cities i mean just
statistically statistically
there's more stuff in this region so it
makes me think maybe the best educated
guest would be right in the middle of
these big cities
um
but there's people talking about perth
you know i'm just gonna go with my
instinct and i'm gonna go right here
okay let's see where we where we're at
not too bad okay it was melbourne
melbourne
um
669 kilometers away not terrible
everybody saying
uh guest perth would have been much more
wrong than i was much much much more
wrong than i was melbourne
melbourne
melbourne
yeah
okay
so there is that
um
do we want to do one in the united
states just as a goof
we only have 50 seconds left that's the
only problem
uh united states
i think we're allowed to make one guess
no matter what all right we've got a
prius and a dodge ram
140th
so
one thing is when i see streets like oh
wait what does that say
hawthorne anybody know what hawthorne
means when i see suburbs or or
neighborhoods like this
with street names like this
i start to think the midwest but these
trees don't look like midwest these
trees to me look more like potentially
northern florida
what do you guys think
if we could get to
some other area the low houses
uh
i wish we could see they really blur out
the license plates in a way that makes
it very very tough
looking to get to a street corner here
we go
greville
no parking
sign oh wait what is this
we could find some kind of uh oh the
trash can sometimes can be good clues
can't tell anything about it
all right let's go to the corner if we
can
hawthorne and 138th
vehicle wraps
hmm
this corner should give us some
information oh three one zero hold on
three one zeros california right
i'm almost positive 3-1-0 is california
3-1-0 watkins welcome
okay so i think we're in
california uh
let's see what else we have here
guaranteed credit approval that that
could be tough
um
[Music]
let's continue down this way
nor benz
310 is socal right like we're not
dealing with the top half for deaf oh
redondo smog
so are we is this redondo beach
let's try redondo beach okay which i
believe is just south of l.a
uh
santa monica hold on it's right around
here redondo beach all right i'm going
with redondo beach let's see what we got
oh my god no not even go oh seven
kilometers oh that's good oh wow okay
guys we did it
we did it folks
seven kilometers
uh i i think we've got to be happy with
seven kilometers right that's
that's gotta be good
okay very good good game everybody all
right
last game for today
uh we're gonna play the higher lower
game
okay the higher lower game we are going
to play classic
higher lower game who what gets googled
more this is a very special day it's a
birthday show all right let's do classic
higher lower
wayne gretzky is searched
201 000 times monthly
versus springer spaniel is springer
spaniel searched more or less
than wayne gretzky
what do people think
most people think higher
i tend to agree
let's go with springer spaniel
no it's lower
wow
all right let's try again
oh god uh oh geez this is not good i
almost want to skip this
holocaust
has 450 000 monthly searches
vanos gaming i don't even know what
vanos gaming is
like it has to be lower if i haven't
heard of it right
lower let's see
lower thank god okay all right we got
that one
thanos gaming versus to kill a
mockingbird that's tough i mean
to kill a mockingbird is is red in so
many places three hundred thousand
searches a month
to kill a mockingbird
this one is tougher
um
a month 300 000
my instinct is lower
no it's higher oh god
all right let's do a couple more
jim carrey 1.5 million monthly searches
versus mental health jim carrey hasn't
even done a movie and who knows how long
and mental health particularly in the
pandemic it's got to be mental health
right
what do people think
i just i can't imagine
higher mental health yeah let's do it
what
what
this is this is crazy
uh all right let's try one more weight
lift
how could there only be 40 000 searches
for weightlifting
versus taxi
this games i'm i'm doubting the accuracy
of this game guys
um
i'm gonna say more for taxi but who the
hell knows yeah okay i mean like yeah i
guess they gave me an easy one all right
we'll go we'll go until uh until we get
one wrong fine taxi versus epic rap
battles
it's just it's tough because
how many people are searching epic rap
battles versus how many people are
having them recommended
yeah
i'm gonna go with lower
okay
it is that's correct 12 000.
epic rap battles versus 2020
i don't even know what that is why is it
spelled does anybody know why it's
spelled that way
20 20. i
i i mean i have no idea and 12 000 is so
low
higher yeah let's just try higher
it was the same though wasn't that was
weird
okay 2020 versus france
france has to be searched more i mean
it's
there's no way right it's got to be
higher
okay good all right now we've got a
streak
france versus muslim uh oh okay
um
france versus muslim
i think i'm going higher for muslim
nope it's lower okay well what do i know
we got a four guys we got a four and the
average score is 3.2 all right
that is gonna do it for me today i want
to thank everybody for joining me on
this very special stream oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad and remember if you
ever find yourselves feeling badly about
yourselves thank your lucky stars every
day you're not dave pagman exactly a
cautionary tale from alex jones thanks
to everybody for joining me predator22
you can use the code
and we'll see everybody very soon